[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si d'abord l'origine de sa leaf nous
sommes créés contre les projets
d'urbanisation massive qui devait
conduire à une augmentation plus de 50%
de la population
c'est ce qui en moins de dix ans voilà
c'est ce qui nous réunit
et nous voulons aussi un autre style de
gouvernance de la ville parce que ces
dernières années on a été exécrable du
point de vue des vip revient nous
apportons en fait une nouvelle vision de
la gestion financière avec d'autres
solutions à préconiser tu es vraiment de
ne pas comment dire pipeauté mais sur la
gestion de la ville
on peut vraiment faire autrement là il
avant co-lead il ne restait plus que
cinq cent mille euros dans les caisses
de l'état et on n'arrête pas de rabâcher
que la ville était bien gérée bien où
depuis le début nous disons qu'il est
une autre façon à faire et que nous
voulons reconstituer le budget de
fonctionnement en arrêtant de
fonctionner sur celui ci pour financer
l'investissement qui nous coûtent plus
cher après en fonctionnement c'est quand
même un cercle infernal qu'on veut
absolument briser urgence en fait ce
sera d'organiser la rentrée scolaire
puisqu'il ya des retards dans l'école il
ya on parle de classe sur sa charge et
avec cette gestion financière et bien
finalement il n'y aura plus une atsem
par classe comme c'était le cas dans des
maternelles donc ça va poser de gros
problèmes pour les familles et la
rentrée et puis bien sûr cet été puisque
tout le monde ne pourra pas partir en
vacances les projets des uns et des
autres sont perturbées donc en train
d'optimiser l'animation après avoir voté
un budget qu'il dix jours après
déduction sur lequel on aura finalement
assez peu d'action à faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]